hi and welcome to clean architecture
with asp net core to - my name is Jason
Taylor I'm a solution architect for SSW
you can find me on Twitter at Jason G
tau or on my blog coding flow net I try
to blog once a week that's my goal I
last blogged in September of 2018 but
hunt Road I've been developing now for
eighteen years and I've learned the most
important principle is kiss or keep it
simple stupid and this principle states
that systems should be made simple
rather than more complex today I'd like
to show you the simplest approach to
developing enterprise architecture with
clean architecture let's get started so
with clean architecture the domain and
the application layer are at the center
of the design the domain contains
enterprise logic and types and the
application layer contains business
logic and types what's the difference
well enterprise logic will be used
throughout multiple systems whereas the
business logic would typically just be
used by this system together the domain
and the application layers make up the
core now rather than have core depend on
concerns such as data access and
persistence we invert those concerns so
infrastructure persistence and
presentation all depend on core now we
achieve this by adding interfaces or
abstractions to core which are
implemented in layers outside of core so
for example if we wanted to implement
the repository pattern we would add an
irepository interface inside core in the
application layer and that would be
implemented within persistence now with
with clean architecture all dependencies
point inwards presentation
infrastructure and persistence all
depend on core but not on one another
and that's very important this results
in an architecture in design that is
independent of frameworks it doesn't
require the existence of some library
it's highly testable we can test all of
core without the need for a database a
web server
äúi we can unit test it off it's
independent of the UI that's a great
place to be right now we're building a
lot of web applications maybe with
angular reactant view and they change
very frequently so we want that
independence pretty soon we're gonna be
writing Blaser apps anyway because we
don't like javascript you like
javascript not me I don't like Telescope
I know this guy and this guy doesn't
like JavaScript it's also independent of
database so we use sequel server we use
Postgres we use Oracle but eventually
we're going to be switching to cosmos DB
because it does everything and it's
independent of anything else external in
fact core doesn't know anything about
the outside world that's what makes
clean architecture great it's the design
that will be there in 15 to 20 years
time even though everything in the
outside world has changed now you can
see that in this particular design
there's only three layers but you can
change that you might have a simpler
requirement and you could use two layers
or you can use more you just need to
remember that those dependencies always
point inwards let's have a look at an
example so my example is Northwind
traders so show of hands who's heard of
Northwind traders okay 50 75 percent of
the room and I know what you're thinking
Northland traders is not cool but you're
wrong I've upgraded it it's now
cross-platform so it doesn't matter if
you're running Windows Mac or Linux you
can run the Northwind traders it's a
running on neck or - - it's running with
energy framework - - it's code first and
it's fully seated sound cool yeah
Northwind traders is cool again let's
have a look at a demo so this solutions
on git on github and I have a link to
the code and slides at the end but let's
have a look at the make up slide down ah
thank you
there we go
okay so you can see the solutions built
split up into number of folders but here
in the source folder we have our core
which contains the domain and
application layer strengths that we have
infrastructure which contains a standard
infrastructure project and a persistence
project and we have a presentation
project which is a web UI that's
currently a single page application
built on angular with net core in common
we just implement our cross-cutting
concerns you'll also note in the
solution that I've added readme and
different projects so you can learn
exactly what goes into each layer and
the slide decks right there okay skip
through that so key points domain
contains the enterprise wide logic and
types that's the logic that can be used
across multiple applications it's not
typically shared the application
contains business logic and types that
the logic that's specific to the
application that we're building
infrastructure including persistence
contains all external concerns and
presentation and infrastructure layers
depend only on application and not on
each other that's a really important
point if we did have presentation
dependent on infrastructure say to send
some notifications or something like
that that forces us to add logic to
presentation we really want that logic
to be in core where we can test it
independent of anything external finally
infrastructure and presentation
components can be replaced with minimal
effort so now we're going to look at
each layer in turn starting with the
domain layer in the domain what would we
expect to see so we'll see entities
value objects enumerations
logic and exceptions custom exceptions
let's have a look in the domain
Oh laughter there we go okay so I want
to look at a few different things in
turn we'll start with this customer
entity that I have good look at this
customer entity you can see that we're
using data annotations throughout and my
recommendation is to use data annotation
sparingly you don't really want to
include these in your domain model
because it's not part of the domain it's
really a persistence concern it's
telling the rme how to map these
entities to the relational model so we
try to keep those out next I want to
talk about value objects so with value
objects we basically create a simple
entity that doesn't have an identity a
value object is equal to another value
object if it has the same value so with
something like an ID account
we could easily encapsulate that as a
primitive type as a string but an ID
account is not a string it's a complex
object with specialized rules in the way
that it's used and when we use that we
typically need different information
from it sometimes we'd like to see the
domain sometimes we'd like to see the
username sometimes we'd like to format
it for display so by including it as a
string we don't have a good place at
least to encapsulate that logic if we
create a value object we can encapsulate
that logic and that makes it easy for
developers to see how to use that so
let's have a look in the value object
I'm able to construct an ad account by
passing in an account string I can split
it up into the domain and the name and
if something goes wrong I can
immediately throw an ad account invalid
exception I can access the domain and
name quite easily and I have a number of
operators for working with ad account
object which makes it quite simple I
have some tests which are really good
demonstration of how to work with it so
you can see this test is quite simple it
just says it should have a valid domain
and name given a valid account string
this one to string returns the correct
format so we're expecting it to be
SSW slash JSON simple the implicit
conversion to string results in correct
string
so we can take a string and we can say
an ad account for that value returns an
ad account which is fine but then we can
implicitly in convert this ad account
value object back to a string just using
the equals operator so that just makes
it easy to work with the ad account if
we do want to display it then we can
explicitly convert from a string to the
domain and name so you can see we take a
string and just cast it directly to the
ad object very simple ad account and we
have our custom exception there so when
you're using primitive types think about
the type of information you're storing
is it really a primitive type is it
really a string is it really an integer
or is it a little bit more complex than
that
are there some rules that you need to
associate with that information that
will make it easier for developers to
work with your system because by doing
that you force them into the pivot pill
of success you make it easier for them
to do the right thing and hard to do the
wrong thing another recommendation I
have further domain is to initialize all
collections so if we have a look at this
order class here you can see that right
at the start I'm initializing the order
details with a default value and down
the bottom
I've actually got a private set on that
so you're not going to be able to
reinitialize it later
so what does that mean it means it's
always ready to use we're not going to
have code in the system that says if
order dot order details equals null then
initialize that's that's really common
we see it all the time especially from
new developers now what's going to
happen is it's always going to be ready
it doesn't matter if you've nude it up
yourself or if it's come back from
entity framework it'll be ready to go
and if a new developer joins 30 and they
try to initialize it they're just going
to get an error and they're gonna see
that oh this is the way that we're doing
things and that's pretty cool that's
that's helping them into the pit of
success so finally and we looked at this
briefly with an ad account I have a
custom exception and it's good to use
custom exceptions in the domain when
necessary because just think about it if
we have a problem constructing an ad
account we're going to throw an ad
account in
exception that's easy to debug that's
easy to handle it's easy to understand
what's not easy to understand is an
index out of range exception that's not
as clear to us as what's actually
happened all right back to the slides
okay so key points
avoid using data annotations use value
objects where appropriate just think is
it really a primitive time or is it a
more specialized object initialize all
collections and use private setters
create custom domain exceptions because
they're going to be a lot easier to
debug now we're going to have a look at
the application layer and this is my
favorite section of the talk in the
application layer we're going to see
interfaces those interfaces and
abstractions for what we will implement
in the external layers
we'll see models view models and DT OS
will see logic this will be our business
logic the special cases that were
handling in this application we'll see
commands in queries we'll talk about
that soon and we'll see validators and
of course application exceptions custom
exceptions that we create for this
application layer so CQRS so everyone
knows that CQRS stands for command query
responsibility segregation and with CQRS
we separate our reads from our write and
the benefits include maximizing
performance and scalability however
that's not the most important thing to
me for me CQRS is about simplicity when
I use it my system becomes easier to
understand and it's easy to add new
features because we can just create a
command or query and it's easy to
maintain our changes are only typically
going to affect a single command or
query and hopefully we're not going to
introduce side-effects or bugs as a
result of change in a single command or
query if you like CQRS you will love
mediator feel like the perfect couple
actually I first heard about mediator in
2017 a good friend of mine bridged
Brendan Richards who's here today
actually said to me I found mediator and
it's awesome and we were in at that time
we were injecting all of these commands
inquiries into controllers and we were
fine with that but Henny's
mediator is awesome we can actually
replace all of that injection and just
inject the eye mediator interface and I
looked at it and I said to him I don't
like that that violates the explicit
dependencies principle but then Steve
Smith who was a really cool developer
told me about it and I thought well he
created the explicit dependencies
principle so I went with it
so sorry Brendan I have my blinkers on
that day so with mediator we define our
commands and queries as requests the
application layer then just becomes a
series of requests and response objects
and with that we gain the ability to
attach additional behavior especially
around cross-cutting concerns so we can
add logging validation and caching with
mediator let's have a look at the
application layer
all right so we'll start by looking at
the customers folder just so we can see
a number of commands and queries I will
zoom in let me get to the place okay so
you can see here we have a number of
commands and a number of queries and
it's really easy with this structure to
see what is inside each folder and and
without deep diving in any deeper
you already know that's that's one of
the great things about it how it's
simplifying the overall design let's
take a look at the create customer
command first so the create customer
command zoom out is oops is a DTO and
it's of of type mediator I request and
basically it contains everything that we
need to create a customer using the
create customer command we also have a
handler and this is of type mediator I
request handler so it's a request
handler for a create customer command
and returns a unit which is saying this
command doesn't return anything if we
look down
we're just injecting the things that we
need so in this case it's the context
the notification service and mediator
and we use all of those things to create
the customer this is actually where we
orchestrate the business case what the
business has defined needs to happen
when we create a customer so you can see
we're adding it to persistence we're
changing the saving the changes and
we're publishing a new customer created
event and later on or we can we can
actually have a look at that now so if
we have a quick peek at this event we
can see the customer created event just
sends a notification that the customer
has been created so I just - just to be
clear each command inquiry encapsulate a
specific business case contains all of
the logic that we need to orchestrate
that business case okay now I want to
talk about data annotations at the
application layer so you saw them here
in the create customer command
and why would we have them there we
might use it for validation but I found
that while data annotations is fine
validation we can do our model state
checks and that's great it's a pretty
nice experience it's not very good for
complex validation what is good at
complex validation is fluent validation
so we can take out all of these data
annotations and just use fluent
validation to achieve the same result
and fluent validation why straight into
the asp.net core validation pipeline so
we're still going to be check to be able
to check model state or if we're using
newer versions such as asp net core - -
it can do it automatically for us so we
can remove those out that makes our DTO
nice and clean and then I'll show you
the fluent validation validator so we
have a customer that's a customer yeah
okay customer validator there we go
and so that's it so you can see for the
create customer command validator
it's still a simple case but let's have
a look at one that's not a simple case
so I have an update customer come on
validator and this is where we actually
have validation which is dependent on
other fields so you can see here this is
a rule for the post code it must match
four digits that's the format of post
codes for Australia so basically if it
doesn't match four digits it'll return
the message Australian post codes have
four digits and then we have another
rule for the phone must have a
Queensland landline when the country is
Australia and the post code starts with
four and you can see there we're calling
a little helper function there so that's
what must have a Queensland landline is
so that's the good thing about fluent
validation and why we don't need data
annotations we can use fluent
validations for our simple validation
scenarios we can use it for our complex
validation scenarios and it was right
into the asp net core pipeline
okay and we talked about the
architecture being independent of
infrastructure and data access concerns
and I just want to have a look here so
if we were to add interfaces and
abstractions it goes right into the
application layer I've got a little
interfaces folder here so you can see
here I just have one single notification
service at the moment and this
notification service just has a single
method and it also has a DTO and you'll
note that the DTO
is also coming from the application
layer so yes we have these external
concerns and they come with their own D
tos so a messaging service that we're
using probably already has a message in
class that we can use but if we bring
that into the application layer then
we're creating a dependency on that
external concern so we actually have to
create the interfaces and any DT O's
that we'll need to communicate with that
service and later on if we need to
switch out that messaging service for
something else so for going from send
grid to something else well that's not
going to be a problem we'll keep our
interface will keep our D tos our unit
tests won't change
it'll just be that service that changes
just the implementation all right so key
points using CQRS and mediator
simplifies your overall design I'm a big
fan of CQRS and I really love using
medio de fluent validation is useful for
all validation scenarios we don't need
double tations in our domain model we
don't need it in the application layer
mediator simplifies cross-cutting
concerns I didn't show you that that was
one of my favorite part let's go back
and circ okay so we talked about
cross-cutting concerns so remember that
in the application layer because we're
using mediator or require all commands
and queries are just requests with
responses so we essentially have a
pipeline they're similar to asp net core
middleware and if you look at how we can
use that in infrastructure i have these
three request behaviors zoom in a little
bit so i've got a request logger a
request performance behavior and a quest
validation behavior so one of the things
that we normally do in asp net core is
to validate our models but the thing
with clean architecture is we're not
necessarily always going to have a web
front-end maybe we have a console UI and
we want to apply that same validation so
while we could write it again it's
actually better just to use a mediator
request validation behavior because then
we get it at the core level and for any
application that execute that command or
query so let's have a look at how simple
it is so you can see here that I've got
a request validation behavior and it is
a generic time with a tea request and a
tea response and it comes from mediators
I pipeline behavior the same types and
you can see here the implementation so
how does this work so the tea request
would be something like a create
customer command or a get customer
detail query and what we do is we search
the assembly to see if there are any
validators associated with that dto the
command or query and we run them if
there are any errors we throw a custom
application exception which contains the
errors and we'll go a little bit deeper
and all the custom application exception
does is put all of the failures into a
dictionary a string representing the
field that has failed and a string array
representing the messages because there
might be multiple failures so it could
be one or more messages for that
particular failure and with that whoops
with that if we
have a look at the presentation layer
just quickly I'll show you how it's used
because it really puts together the
whole experience so I have this custom
exception filter and essentially if
there's an exception which could happen
in an application layer and it's a
validation exception then it catches
that exception and it automatically
returns a bad request with all of those
failures in exactly the same shape as it
would be if it has been returned from
model state so we get the same
experience all right back to the slide
deck yes yes I can the the wonderful
thing is we'll go to the customers
controller because that's the example we
don't do anything and we'll get a look
at this in more detail we don't have to
have any validation handling in the
controller because we've implemented it
in core and what happens is this filter
this custom exception filter actually
fires if there's an exception within the
action and takes over the response type
so it actually says oh there's an
exception I'll catch that it's a
validation exception as you can see here
and I'll I will set the response to bad
request and I will return you a JSON
result which is the validation failures
so you see we don't have to handle it in
the controller and we also well we would
if we wrote a console application we'd
want to catch that exception in some way
but this is how we're catching it in the
case of asp net core good question
all right key points using well we've
covered those two so mediator simplifies
cross-cutting concerns and the design is
independent of infrastructure and data
access concerns so you notice me using
ADB context in my commands and queries
and you might be thinking well it's it's
not independent of data access because
we use any of core let's talk about that
now so in the persistence layer we're
going especially if we're using EF core
we're going to be using a DB context
will have migrations configurations
seeding and abstractions so if we're
implementing maybe the repository in the
unit of the work that would be an
example so the big question should we
implement the unit of work and
repository patterns so show of hands
when we're using the of core who thinks
we should ok there's maybe like seven
people show of hands who thinks we
shouldn't okay maybe about twenty people
that's not everyone but that's okay
that's it that's in the indication so I
think it's not always the best choice
because if core insulates your code from
database changes how does it do that
well EF core is one big abstraction with
EF core we choose a provider sequel
server oracle Postgres and by changing
out the provider we change the database
that we're dependent on so we're not
actually dependent on a specific
database provider we can switch that up
so we might need to delete our
migrations and ricci receded and sorry
recreate an initial migration that's
specific for the provider that were
chosen there hopefully not much more
than that also if you like the unit of
work well that's good DB context is a
unit of work and if you like the
repository that's good too DB set is a
repository one of the one of the things
that was common teaser repository and a
unit of work for in previous versions of
energy framework was for unit testing
and that was a really good use case for
repositories at that point but now we
have great testing tools so we've got
the EF core in-memory provider yet
another
core provider we can switch that in for
our unit testing all our unit tests will
run in memory but what do the experts
think so first we have Jimmy Bogart he's
the creator of Auto mapper mediator at
the conference this this week and he
thinks I'm over repositories and
definitely over abstract in your data
layer so he's he's against repositories
we have Steve Smith Microsoft MVP and
longtime Regional Director and he thinks
you don't need a repository but there
are many benefits and you should
consider it now Steve has talked and
blogged for length about repositories
and I think when he says that he's being
diplomatic
I think he's against repositories but if
you like repositories the good news is
he has a lot of great information on how
to build really good repositories using
the specification patterns so check that
stuff out finally we have John Smith so
he's the author of the new book EF core
in action and he thinks no the
repositories last unit of work pattern
isn't useful with EF core so he's
against repositories too so what should
we do when all of the experts don't
agree we take it back to basics we
realize that repositories and unit of
work are design patterns they're
designed to solve a problem if that
particular pattern solves a problem you
have then you should use it if it does
not solve that problem then you'll just
be introducing unnecessary complexity so
that's the only thing you need to
remember let's have a look at the
persistence layer
all right so the first thing that I want
to show you if I can scroll
let's contract if we look at the CS proj
we can see that we're independent of the
database I can switch that out that
provider out for Postgres and we'll
still be able to use it with this
particular solution we have switched
without for with Postgres and it didn't
impact anything it's not always going to
be the case but we're at least we're off
to a good start now the next thing that
I'd like to say is to prefer fluent API
configuration over data annotations so
we mentioned before that we could use
data annotations to help with the
mapping from our object model to our
relational model but we can also use
fluent API configuration and that's just
a better choice because then we're not
cluttering our entities with those data
annotations and in actual fact you can
do more with with fluent then you can
with data annotations let me load up one
because I want to make another point on
that so in the customer configuration
you can see that we can describe all of
those properties that we would have used
for data annotations but it's really
important to know the conventions when
you're working with any conventions
based framework because in this case
we're actually specifying that you know
well actually not not in though I've got
a better example order configuration so
in the in this in this particular case
we're defining that order ID is a
primary key but if we know entity
framework well we know that if there's
an entity named order and there's a
property named ID or order ID with a
vary in case it already knows it's a
primary key so yes
use use energy type configurations but
know your conventions and make your life
a little bit easier for that that's true
of any conventions based framework if
you know the conventions it'll be easier
to work with it
one other thing with all of these
configurations there are a few different
ways to apply it but fortunately
if cor 2:2 we now have a new method and
it can apply all of those configurations
automatically for us so we used to have
to say model builder don't apply
configuration and you up the
configuration always forget and that
would you know catch us but now we can
just run that so that's quite quite good
that came in too too
all right so key points its independent
of the database we're using the e of
core providers and so we're kind of safe
we use fluent API configuration over
data annotations they're more powerful
we prefer conventions over configuration
we know our conventions and therefore
were more effective when we design our
systems and we automatically apply all
entity type configurations using the F
Court to apply or configurations method
all right now let's have a look at the
infrastructure layer so you know
infrastructure layer we have
implementations
it contains classes for accessing
external resources so for example it
could be API clients if we're
communicating with some other web api
for our system if we need to access the
file system email notifications the
system clock is a good one you might
think you know day time dot now is
pretty safe in your code but if you've
got any kind of logic that's based on
the current date and time you need to
abstract that otherwise it's going to be
hard to unit test really the
infrastructure layer contains anything
fixed oh when we talk about
infrastructure we really are talking
about persistence as well but it makes
sense to split them up and how many in
this solution you know there's one
infrastructure project but it really
depends on the complexity of what's
going in there if you're if you're
implementing security that's probably
going to be an entirely separate project
but it would go into the infrastructure
layer so let's have a look at the
infrastructure layer so I don't have too
much in the infrastructure layer for
this particular example I do have an
implementation for machine date/time so
you can see that's quite simple but when
we go to unit tests we can substitute
high date time with something else so
say if we had some logic that was
dependent on a Tuesday you know this
particular logic only fire on Tuesday
well we can substitute in an IDE a time
that tells the test that it's a Tuesday
so it's as simple as that
actually we had another nice benefit in
a project that I was involved in because
we had that I date/time implemented
really well throughout the system we're
actually able to provide the front-end
testers with a new tool they could
adjust the system day
time using a menu item in configuration
so that their testing was more effective
they could actually move it forward and
move it back and set it back to actual
system time so that was good for them
for the exploratory testing we also have
the implementation for the notification
service it's a bit lightweight but it's
really quick so this is the notification
service that we saw earlier in the
application layer so it's using the
interface from the application layer and
it's using the type from the application
layer so whatever we put in here is
going to be external of course so the
other important thing and we mentioned
this at the beginning but it's important
to mention again is that no layers
should depend on infrastructure layer it
doesn't have any dependencies sorry it
depends on core but nothing depends on
it because as soon as and I've seen this
before and that's why I'm saying it
again if you have a dependency going
from presentation to infrastructure then
things start to break down because you
have to create that logic inside of
presentation and that logic can't be
shared by other applications that are
connecting to it all the dependencies
point in words that means all the logic
will be orchestrated within core that
means any you is that you add to a layer
will benefit from that logic
all right so key points so the
infrastructure layer contains classes
for accessing external resources such as
file systems web services SMTP and so on
anything external it implements
abstractions / interfaces to find within
the application layer and no layers
depending on the infrastructure layer eg
presentation layer so finally we're
going to look at the presentation layer
so as I mentioned this is a asp net core
- - weber running angular so in the
presentation layer it can be whatever we
want it could be spa angular efu web api
razor pages blazer MVC web forms even it
really doesn't matter everything's in
core let's have a look so the first
thing I want to do is take a little bit
of a tour of particular controller in
this solution it's got quite a lot of
history behind it and it's good to see
kind of the evolution as we implemented
these various features in the system and
what kind of impact it had
okay well I really want that come back
okay
scroll down oh no this is the wrong one
sorry we're gonna look at the products
controller okay first we'll look at this
one so you can see here this is a really
typical controller and something that
you've seen many times before we have a
products controller and into this
controller we inject the dbcontext we're
returning entities directly from the
controller and it's it's not it's a
trivial controller but even so it's
quite verbose there's quite a lot
happening there's a few things wrong
with this the first thing is that we've
brought in something like the DB context
which is a really low level concept for
something that's really on the edge of
our architecture and design so we only
have one place left to put the logic and
that's in the actions of the controller
now we can't really share that we could
get crazier maybe start referencing
controllers in console apps and stuff
and share it that way but that's that's
not gonna work nobody's going to do that
the other problem we have is we're
returning entities and entities are
another really low level concept you
know we need to return view models
because when we return a product maybe
we're going to edit that product there's
not enough information in a product
entity to actually edit a product we
need a list of suppliers we need a list
of categories we need all sorts of
information that's why we typically
return view models not too much else
happening here we've got some checks and
bits and pieces of logic let's move on
history its customers control there it
is okay mmm
I think this one so this is where this
is where we were using commands and
queries before I started listening to
Steve Smith
so we're injecting all of these commands
and queries everything that the
controller needs and the good thing
about that is we're no longer returning
entities and we no longer have
dependency on the DB context at this
level so we are able to encapsulate our
logic within a specific query or command
and we can encapsulate whatever we need
in the DT or view model that we returned
then we found out about from services
from services is really cool so it's
just a feature with the dependency
injection built Internet core where we
can actually inject at a method level
the thing that we need so you can see
here for this post product action we're
injecting a I create product command and
we can use that to execute the command
and you can see even at this stage this
control is starting to get quite concise
there's only one or two lines of code
and there's certainly no logic within
there so it's a big improvement and then
we started using mediator
so with mediator we're injecting a
mediator and we don't need to actually
inject the commands and queries anymore
that it's all wired up we saw the
commands and queries were implementing I
request mediator requests and the
handlers were implementing our request
handler so you can see things are really
simple we're just we're just executing
queries and executing commands
oops
let's see it's been lots of changes
let's just go to the latest one so this
is what it looks like today we're not
even injecting media though we have a
base control to take care of that for us
you can see here that it's quite simple
we don't really need to do too much and
that's wonderful our controllers have
become a piece of infrastructure their
responsibility now is to take a request
and to turn it into a response and
nothing else all of the logic behind
that request all of the processing the
orchestration that we need to do is
handled elsewhere it's a question in the
application layer yeah that's it that's
a good point and a point that I didn't
make you have only good questions thank
you let's find that so actually there's
two points so when we looked at create
customer what you may have noticed so
I'm just assuming it is everything
that's associated with creating a
customer is in the same folder so if we
do need to change the create customer
come on we're not going to be jumping
around to different folders to do that
everything is there we have the command
itself the DTO
with which we make the request we have
the handler the class that's responsible
for handling the request and we have the
validator the class that's responsible
for validating the DTO
and then we have our customer created
event so it's all there that's a that's
a really good way to organize your files
so the DTO is there we have a look at
products actually the queries
ah there we go so there's our DTRS all
located together with the queries all
commands and you might think well I want
to put them in a central location and I
want to share them because I use
products in more than one place and that
that's that can be the case the problem
with that however is usually there is
some difference in the way you're using
product so for example you might want a
list of products and you might just want
the idea in the name but of course when
you're editing a product you want kind
of the full DTO
now if you start reusing those models
what can happen is you can introduce
side effects so you go to change one
query or command and you break another
query or command so I think it's better
to not reuse the details unless they're
absolutely trivial and to keep them
separate so that way when you change one
thing you don't have to worry about side
effects let's see there was one other
point I want to make is one of the
things that new developers will often
complain about when they first start
working with CQRS is discoverability if
we go to zoom out that's not zooming out
if we go to the customers controller and
we have a look at the commands or the
queries it's easy for us to jump
directly to the query we can just press
f12 and we're there but it's not easy
for us to jump to the handler and that's
really where we want to go most of the
time so there's actually an alternative
approach that you can use so instead of
creating separate commands and command
handlers you can take the handler the
class and nest it directly into the
command and that's actually my preferred
approach I can in fact if I undo the
changes where it's that our go team
Explorer changes
there so now we have the create customer
command including the handler at the top
we have all of the properties that are
associated with this DTO then we have
the handler and the implementation for
that handler so maybe you like that
maybe you don't but it's it's one way to
do it and it does improve
discoverability so now when we go from
the controller to the create customer
come on everything that the developer is
expecting to see is there so I think
that's kind of nice okay next thing that
I want to show is open API so I think
everyone has heard of open API if they
haven't then they've heard of swagger so
we won't go into that but I want to show
you the particular implementation that
I'm using and I find it really useful
I've gone through through a number of
different variations so I'm using n swag
and you can see here I have an inspired
configuration file and this particular
configuration file without going to the
boring details will do two things for me
first it will create the open API
specification document so that other
systems can interact with my system and
the second thing it will do is to create
an angular client so that I can
automatically interact with my back-end
API from angular and what it creates for
me is something quite wonderful it
creates all of the services and all of
those details or view models in
typescript I don't have to create those
myself it saves me a lot of time and I
found that the code it produces is
exceptional and that's what you want the
source of truth is in that application
layer in core we don't want to recreate
them from scratch which is what we used
to do in the past we want them to be
generated based on the source of truth
and this is so effective in you can see
in my web UI if I edit the CS project I
have an msbuild task which will actually
run n swag from the command line and
generate the specification and generate
that angular typescript client whenever
our controller changes
so whenever anything changes it's
automatically rebuilt now if you've been
developing with angular you know that
angular will automatically pick up those
changes as well so if something changes
in your web by API that causes a
breaking change angular is going to pick
it up straight away and it's going to
tell you so it's a really nice
experience and within swag of course we
have good tooling so we have the N spark
studio and we can use it to generate a
number of things so this is the azuma
and we'll have a look at exactly what
we're generating for this project I
think I'm just wanting to have a look
yeah ok so this is the specification
that gets generated on build and it gets
actually put onto the file system you
can do the generation of the
specification at runtime but I find that
problematic because at runtime we have
to deal with things like permissions and
authentication so you can see the
specification is just plain Jason it's
not really for us to read there's the
typescript client and you can see
typescript clients really great it's
really long it contains all of the
services so you know we have a products
controller so there's going to be a
products client so we can access all of
those methods but I want to show you a
DTO
is an employee manager model so that's
the type that exists in core and it's
been recreated for us in typescript
ready to go and of course we've got
swagger UI in the background so that
makes it easy for developers to work
with our system they can see and explore
our API they can try out methods if they
want to which is great
there we go nice and easy so it just
gives us a number of and it just really
what I like to say is that open API no
matter which tool you're using bridges
the gap between the front end and the
back end of my slides
alright so key points controllers should
not contain any application logic we've
worked really hard now and all of that
logic has moved into core where it
belongs we should create and consume
well-defined view models entities are
not sufficient to return to the client
we need something more specific based on
whatever whatever command or query is
related to open API bridges the gap
between the front end and the back end
so I have some recommended resources the
first one this is a book by Steve Smith
architecting modern web applications
with asp net core and azure this is a
great book it's a quick read this is
where I first learn about clean
architecture one thing I will say if
you're not into Azure don't worry it
really doesn't impact the content of the
book it's it's excellent and I'll share
a link to the slides in code as well
next one is building micro services this
is really a companion book to the first
book and keep in mind if you're not into
containers and you're not into Azure
that's ok all of the content in this
book is still really relevant I highly
recommend you know if you liked what you
saw today those are two really good
books to get started with and of course
we have clean architecture by Uncle Bob
it would be a mess of me not to not to
mention the actual the book that was
published on this so thanks for coming
to my talk today if you're keen to learn
more please download the code and slides
and try it out for yourself I think
you're going to find that clean
architecture is simple to implement all
the way from development to production
thank you
[Applause]
happy to take any questions yes yes